I have a problem with ketchup but before
we get to that I have a problem with
some other things first
first up oh the cheese challenge now
folks I love an Internet challenge I
really do but this the just tossing
cheese on to an unsuspecting child it's
absolutely real look it up it's just
we're better than this let me ask this
what happened to things like the
mannequin challenge where everyone just
kind of stands still and we're all like
damn that's that's pretty cool there are
challenges like that I want more of
though because right now we're throwing
cheese on babies you got your cheese and
it just goes right on the baby's face
and dad doesn't stop there you got your
people throwing cheese on the dogs we
got people throwing cheese on the cats
we got people and someone probably threw
cheese on there grandma honestly I don't
think I fault the person who started
this was it funny the first time I'm
actually not sure both we don't all have
to see that and then dude just let some
things be we can just appreciate things
from afar and then wait for a challenge
that doesn't involve confuse the less
smart creature by throwing cheese or
berries oh okay trailers before trailers
not relaxed this one actually has me
really heated I the only one before a
new movie trailer plays there is a
preview of what the full preview will be
it'll be like that movie noise that we
all know the main character like jumping
out of a helicopter and then the day it
comes out then the regular trailer
starts are we so busy that we need to
watch a thing that makes us want to
watch the longer thing that makes us
want to watch the longest thing if you
haven't noticed this yet you will now
you know what I want to know I want to
know right now who is the person about
to watch the new Mission Impossible
trailer and thinks I don't know if I
have a minute and 45 seconds to watch
this can I see a trailer for the trailer
we are not that busy
whoo I'm sweating okay thank you for
sticking with me we've done it we made
it ketchup I have a problem with it the
problem is I don't like now before you
jump down my throat
scream in my face kick me in the teeth
everybody chill let me explain the other
day in a casual conversation
I mentioned that I don't like ketchup
almost immediately everyone around what
my ketchup oh cool what is wrong and I
don't think that's right but the thing
is it gets worse you know I feel all
backed into a corner so I lash out
I get nasty I come for ketchup let's
take I take shots at ketchup I say
things like it's not good it's too sweet
everything that it's on only tastes like
ketchup it stains everything it's got a
funky smell it isn't tomatoes and it's
just flat-out overeating listen I don't
mean those things not all of them then
the people who snapped me in the first
place get even more freaked out and here
we are there aren't many of us but there
certainly are some of us who just don't
like ketchup and that's it let's just
let it be that I'm not here to convince
you not to like ketchup go ahead drink
it for all I care but also don't try to
destroy me like everybody chill I guess
my issue is that ketchup is tearing us
apart
I'm allowed to not like ketchup you're
allowed to like
I just need a trip getting out there I
promise to stop coming for ketchup I
promise to be less defensive about not
liking ketchup if you promise to not
freak out when I tell you I don't like
ketchup however if you put ketchup all
over an order fries so help me God
[Music]